i've got two more videos for you in
closing
this one came out yesterday and it's
like
they just lie
they just lie they know they're lying
they know we know they're lying and yet
they continue to lie here's joe biden
claiming that republicans are trying to
stop black people from voting yesterday
we're going to keep pushing on this and
we're protecting our country's threshold
liberty the sacred right to vote which
i've never seen is under such attack
you know it's always made it harder for
blacks to vote but this is trying to be
able to figure out how to keep the black
vote when it occurs from even counting
over the past year
we've directed federally
like the two morons in the back that
don't even know what they're applauding
i mean first off again biden is just
bumbling and mumbling and he doesn't
really say things in a proper way but
you sort of get the idea uh that
republicans are mean and they're
stopping black people from voting and
that's what they used to do and they're
doing it even worse now
not true do you know what republicans
are trying to do they're trying to make
sure that you have an id when you vote
and i guarantee you if you're watching
this you have some sport some form of
identification do you guys have
identified
yeah okay everyone in this room has
identification these aren't the
brightest people in the world okay
that's pretty good but i'm just saying
if these guys can do it you can do it
okay all right now i feel like i have to
get you guys guacamole today on the
chipotle after that that very intense
insult um everyone has id everyone has
id you need an id to get
on a plane you need an id to rent a golf
cart or whatever else you might be doing
so he's just lying and they just know
that they can lie over and over and
imply that the other people are racist
while they are really the racist
and then i thought this would be the
perfect one to end on just yesterday
once again
dr jill biden and it's very important
that you refer to her as a doctor okay
which if anything she should be
examining joe which i guess she hasn't
gotten around to
um she was introducing uh kamala harris
said you're not gonna
take a look ladies
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the uni the vice president
[Applause]
i just said that to make you laugh
the vice president of the united states
scotland
why do they keep making this mistake joe
keeps making it dr jill keeps making it
everyone keeps making the same mistake
can we throw it up again i mean i just
have to with the audio
ladies and gentlemen
that's my husband there i think he's the
president but i'm gonna gentlemen
the president of the united vice
president
this idiot couldn't be in charge look at
him sitting there he doesn't know what
he's doing he's wearing a mask for no
reason
[Applause]
to make you laugh i'm hilarious my
writers gave me this one i've got 20
writers and they thought it would be
funny if i mistook the president of the
united states again lordy lordy lordy